le plus inquiétant ce soir reste le
nuage de particules radioactives
on sait il s'est déplacé de tout d'abord
vers la scandinavie puis est en train de
descendre vers le sud
alors comment peut-on prévoir son
déplacement les explications brigitte
simonetta il faut bien ça la différence
entre le possible et le réel
d'abord les certitudes lors de
l'accident
un anticyclone se trouvait sur l'union
soviétique autour des hautes pressions
on sait que les vents s'enroule dans le
sens des aiguilles d'une montre
les particules radioactives sont alors
dans un premier temps remonter sur la
pologne puis elles ont continué leur
chemin et atteint en 48 heures les pays
scandinaves
depuis lundi la situation n'a pas changé
ces particules sont donc de plus en plus
nombreuses à atterrir sur la suède
maintenant les prévisions une dépression
a pris place sur la sardaigne
là les vents tournent dans le sens
inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
si l'émission radioactifs persistait
tout laisse à penser que cette poussière
aspirer depuis l'ukraine seraient
renvoyés vers l'italie
la yougoslavie et l'autriche en france
l'anticyclone des açores s'est
développée la météo affirme qu'il
restera jusqu'à vendredi prochain
suffisamment puissant pour offrir une
véritable barrière de protection
ils bloquent en effet toutes les
perturbations venant de l'est
mais attention ces prévisions sont
établies pour trois jours reste à savoir
combien de temps il faudra encore pour
éteindre l'incendié
ce furent les pays scandinaves qui
furent les premiers pays alerté la
finlande le danemark et la suède la
suède où l'on recommande maintenant de
faire attention aux pluies
car en effet il a plu ces derniers jours
et l'on demande aux habitants se doit
d'éviter de boire les pluies de
ruissellement voici le reportage à
uppsala près de stockholm de nos envoyés
spéciaux
hervé brusini et aimer mayol on ne